The extension of the post study visa
which is the subclass four eighty five uh
which started last year July 2,023
they introduced that some eligible qualification
will be eligible for an additional
one to two years of 4 85 visa. So that uh
option will no longer be available from mid 2,024.
So that will go away soon
but until it does go away
you do have the option of
uh you know
using this opportunity and getting your extension
for the 4 85 visa.
Now keep in mind
there is another extension which is for the regional ah
which is the regional extension.
So for example
if you have studied and lived in a regional area
and you have done a higher education qualification
you will be eligible for an extension
depending on where you studied and lived
depending on the postcode.
So that extension is still available
but the extension
where you have to prove that you've done an eligible
qualification
that will go away mid 2,020.